[Musique]
avec Julien chahida bonjour Julien
bonjour pour commencer votre revue de
presse le réchauffement climatique qui
s'accélère et qui pourrait bien s'avérer
bien pire que prévu effectivement si
jamais vous connaissez l'adage la maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs et
peut-être bientôt nous disent de
Guardian pardon peut-être que bientôt
donc pourrons plus vraiment fermer les
yeux avec en une du quotidien
britannique cette photo d'une forêt en
feu situation qui se répète maintenant
chaque été à travers le monde et surtout
ce titre pas de retour en arrière point
d'interrogation le journal fait écho aux
inquiétudes de l'ONU sur nos capacités
réelles à contenir à la hausse des
températures à 1,5 degré et mais cela en
parallèle notamment avec les super
profits qu'on voit ici en une j'agrandi
un petit peu de l'organisation shell
super profit réalisé par les géants
pétroliers avec l'annonce de bénéfices
record au premier trimestre ça c'est
pour la presse britannique on va faire
un petit tour du côté de la presse
française avec libération qui titres
aussi sur le redout qu'on connaît
actuellement en France surtout le
territoire le redout qu'on redoute jolie
jeu de mot de du quotidien de gauche je
vais rentrer dans le quotidien et voici
ce que nous dit libération des
températures anormales qui inquiète les
scientifiques pourquoi et bien parce que
après un été qui a connu plusieurs
vagues de sécheresse
pardon on pensait que l'automne serait
une accalmie pour le climat français
bien pas du tout car à court terme
pourrait y avoir un problème d'accès à
l'eau si ça continue comme ça dit
certains spécialistes il y a ici à côté
de cet article une photo de la Garonne à
Toulouse qui est à son plus bas niveau
en cette saison avec cette photo d'un
pêcheur et l'article nous dit que
bientôt si ça continue comme ça et bien
on ne pourra plus continuer à pêcher
faute de poisson c'est le moment de
rappeler Julien que cela fait plusieurs
décennies que les écologistes tentent
d'alerter l'opinion sur l'urgence de la
situation mais face à l'accélération du
réchauffement climatique certains ont
choisi des méthodes disons originales
pour se faire entendre pour tenter de
faire bouger la ligne ouais le mot est
bien choisi de votre part je vous
montrer rapidement cette photo de
habitants écologiste ça se passe dans un
musée au Pays-Bas devant je ne sais pas
si on le voit très bien ici juste
derrière cet homme au crâne chauve la le
tableau très célèbre de Vermeer de la
jeune fille à la perle ce militant
écologiste se colle littéralement le
crâne contre le tableau pour interpeller
la population et c'est une méthode qu'on
a déjà vu récemment aux États-Unis en
Grande-Bretagne pardon dans un musée
londonien c'était avec les tournesols de
Van Gogh cette fois-ci ce sont deux
jeunes filles deux activistes
écologistes qui s'étaient qui avait
aspergé le tableau de Van Gogh dessous à
chaque fois les tableaux n'ont rien
puisqu'ils sont vitrifiés ils sont
protégés comment attirer l'attention
médiatique nous deux se demandent le
monde quand on a peu de moyens mais une
cause à défendre le monde qui revient
sur ses activistes qui pour alerter sur
le réchauffement climatique s'en
prennent à des œuvres d'art avec comme
interrogation à chaque fois ces œuvres
d'Arves va-t-elle valent-elles plus que
nos vies une forme de militantisme menée
en Grande-Bretagne je vous le disais
avec ce mouvement qui s'appelle just
stop oil et qui en Allemagne et en
France notamment pour ces militants
explique la presse américaine et
notamment je vais vous le montrer tout
de suite le New York Times pour ces
militants le but n'est pas de saccager
des chefs évidemment puisqu'il vise à
chaque fois des tableaux protégés mais
de choquer l'opinion quitte à être un
populaire voire même incompris pour le
moment l'intérêt du style c'est que
l'attention qu'ils attire leur
permettent de faire passer leur message
sauf que nous dit le quotidien américain
cela peut être à double tranchant quand
on jette de la soupe ou de la purée sur
Van Gogh est-ce que la terre peut gagner
c'est ici juste là entrez qu'un des
Earth win c'est difficile évaluer car si
la cause peut être noble les moyens sont
plus discutables nous dit l'article
surtout lorsqu'ils sont peu appréciés
par la plupart des climatologues nous
restons après ces américaines nous
allons maintenant parcourir le
Washington Post avec le sujet dont on a
parlé il y a quelques instants ici le
rachat de Twitter par Elon Musk oui 44
milliards vous le disiez 44 milliards de
dollars pour acquérir l'un des réseaux
sociaux les plus influents Dumont c'est
la photo de l'homme du jour et la muse
que l'homme le plus riche du monde aussi
il avait jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour
officialiser son rachat sous peine de
procès quasiment perdus nous rappelle le
Washington Post et à peine racheté Elon
Musk imposé sa griffe sur l'entreprise
avec le licenciement de tament Manu
military des principaux dirigeants
est-ce que cela va changer quelque chose
pour le milliardaire oui cela peut alors
avec Elon Musk il faut dire que c'est
toujours assez flou en termes de
stratégie sur le plan comptable c'est
difficile à déterminer car Twitter au
contraire d'autres réseaux sociaux
gagnent assez peu d'argent il aurait
tendance il aurait même tendance à en
perdre c'est en tout cas ce que nous dit
de New yor Times mais ce qui est sûr
c'est quel ad musk gagner en influence
et peut et peut-être ça d'ailleurs son
véritable objectif le New York Times qui
titres avec ce qui donne cet article
avec ce titre un petit peu accrocheur
comment Elen musk est devenu un agent du
chaos géopolitique mondial depuis
plusieurs années le milliardaire ou même
le multimilliardaire n'a pas hésité à
s'immiscer dans différents conflits de
la planète ordonnance en opinion sur les
relations ou les difficultés des
relations entre Taïwan et la Chine et
tout récemment sur son compte Twitter en
proposant un plan de paix très précis
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie plante pays
qui étaient disons franchement plutôt
favorable à Moscou et qui n'a vraiment
vraiment pas plu aux Ukrainiens
rapidement mars rapidement termine sur
la planète Mars bien sûr avec cette
annonce qui a été faite hier par la NASA
de la découverte de 2 de la détection
pardon de 2 tremblements de terre
martiens si on puis dire autrement de
mars c'est vous qui voyez qui se sont
produits à la fin de l'année 2021 ce
sont les deux plus gros impacts de
météorites jamais détectés dans tout le
système solaire on a ici une vue
d'artiste avec des projectiles qui ont
été quand même répartis sur un rayon de
37 km et le Garden nous explique en fait
que ces cratères ici vous avez l'un des
deux cratères qui fait quand même 150
mètres de diamètre sécrateurs en fait
ont permis de déceler de la glace d'eau
qui était qui était sous la sous la dans
la terre martienne Glasgow qui pourrait
à mettre donc à servir pour de
prochaines explorations spatiales merci
beaucoup